en la devastada ciudad de adillaman las
excavadoras continúan removiendo
escombros de edificios la mayoría de los
residentes han huido Pero los que quedan
viven con miedo e intentan sobrevivir
nuevamente
duermo al aire libre Esto no es vivir
realmente estamos pasando los días con
pan sopas y comida como parte de la
ayuda que envía la gente ya no tenemos
vida tenemos miedo no hemos entrado a
ningún edificio hasta ahora
la sobrevivientes
en 10 días se reportaron 4.300 pero
muchos se enfrentan a una nueva amenaza
contraer enfermedades por malas
condiciones sanitarias en este
campamento de antioquía la falta de agua
potable y baños podría provocar brotes
de cólera o fiebre tifoidea mientras que
los desechos humanos se derraman sobre
los escombros por la noche las
temperaturas pueden descender a 0 grados
en condiciones tan frías muchos
desarrollan infecciones de las vías
respiratorias superiores esto es vital
improvisado en alejandreta Trata a
varios cientos de pacientes al día
casi de 50% de los pacientes llega por
estrés postraumático los demás son por
hipotermia les da resfriado común
lastimosamente podemos tener 500 600
bajas en un día
pero un nuevo peligro se cierne sobre
los residentes la liberación de
sustancias tóxicas como el asbesto de
los edificios destruidos obligándolos a
buscar máscaras para ayudar a las
víctimas del terremoto la ONU hizo un
llamado de ayuda por mil millones de
dólares para una operación de Socorro
tras el terremoto